since his comedy career first kicked off
what has accomplished quite a lot but
this weekend might be his biggest stage
yet I met up with the comedian to learn
a thing or two about writing jokes and
the journey that led him to this major
milestone
Milestone I was raised in the South I am
a child of the South bury me in the
south
but this is where it all started and you
haven't been back here
since you were like one I've never
visited this place as an adult
although comedian Roy Wood Jr was born
here in New York City his childhood
memories are of Birmingham Alabama the
place he truly calls home what was your
childhood like you know we live on the
west side of Birmingham and West End
there were gangs there was a lot of like
everything that you think the 80s was
with white flight and Crag it was around
but wood kept on the right path with the
help of his mother Joyce a school
administrator and his father Roy senior
a highly regarded journalist who founded
the first national radio network owned
by black Americans break that down for
me what was his mindset anywhere where
is black folks in drama
and guns
he will pull up his father survived
reporting in war zones but lost his
battle with pancreatic cancer my father
died my senior year of high school and
he was for the most part a significant
part of the income in the house we were
a two income home so I got a job I
started working at Baskin Robin I was
working at Subway I was working 30 35
hours a week between all those jobs wood
ended up earning a degree in journalism
too studying at Florida a m University
FAMU before he was suspended over
stealing so wait let's talk about that
you could be stealing credit cards and
selling stolen clothes on campus and
think we're just going to let you
continue your education so fam you set
my ass down but that's what I needed and
like once I got back in school I was
Dean's List the rest of the way Wood
recognizes the university may have
believed in him more than he did himself
black children are
told from an early age that they are
disposable and I think it is important
to be in a place where there's people
around you who can remind you that your
life isn't disposable because a lot of
those people were probably almost
dispose themselves I mean y'all know
some of these amusement parks up to like
four dollars for a sip of lemonade
that was forty seven dollars right there
oh that's when I started doing stand-up
I don't know how blessings work but I
know that I was at a low and I found
something that was an outlet for being
at a low the girl called me up she's
like Roy did you have on a condom I'm
like yes I had on a condom she said good
because I don't want to be stuck with
yourself
when I was in college I'd take my joke
book to church and my mom used to get
mad at me for doing it so I would just
write on the church program
just premises would just fly in my head
so a premise like you know something you
notice in church something you know just
the most indecent thing you can
non-Christian thought you can have and I
would just be like that'll be good
it is God giving me I came to church to
get my reopening jokes like that's a
quick one-liner about interracial dating
he's kept all of those joke books some
dating back 20 years here's one used to
be a time on this Earth You could give a
girl scout four dollars three months
later five five UPS trucks pull up to
your house I gave a Girl Scout four
dollars she brought me back six Oreos
yeah these ain't even Girl Scout cookies
please welcome Roy Wood Jr with time his
jokes only got better in 2006 he made
his National Television debut on The
Late Show with David Letterman you ever
been on a date so bad the girl makes you
drop her off at another dude's house she
hasn't been through that he followed
that Milestone as a finalist on NBC's
Last Comic Standing in 2008.
and eventually landed stand-up gigs on
Comedy Central
ups and for the anthem
change the song
that's half the problem right there now
25 years into his career wood is in his
prime he's a father to six-year-old
Henry and a correspondent on The Daily
Show which city treats black people the
best
[Applause]
it's Atlanta actually which he guests
hosted earlier this month after Trevor
Noah sign off in December but look at
that outfit
Gwyneth Paltrow showed you the cheat
code boy
you got to dress like you don't give a
if they were to offer you the job
what would you say
if I'm offered an opportunity to have a
direct line to Americans every night
four nights a week
you can't say no to that often also I'm
you know I've already live here it's
easy I know that you're new
a love for laughter has led wood to
perhaps his biggest Milestone yet being
the Entertainer of this year's White
House correspondence dinner when we talk
about Legacy that'll be something that
you'll be able to point to for your
children for your children's children
it's an honor to speak
and crack jokes on top of that
you know next to the president but I
think it's an even bigger responsibility
to be able to talk directly to the
people in the room that are pushing
against a lot of the things that keep
America from moving forward because I
think the job of comedian is to be the
voice of the regular person
being the voice for others a lesson
learned from his father do you think
that he would find this a moment to
applaud
I think my father would be proud
but I think he'd be even prouder if I go
up there and make sure that I'm talking
about something real
because when you have the microphone you
better have something to say
you may not get it again
well Goosebumps right right you should
mention you can catch Roy wood Jr's
special commentary mic drop on BET news
magazine American black the show is a
partnership between bet and CBS News but
I think he's going to kill it I think
he's going to kill it oh yeah so many
are pulling for him he is such a
thoughtful I mean he's very funny AF
right we were all laughing just those
little Snippets that we played
yes oh yeah funny as fuzz okay yes
that's exactly what I mean got it um but
you know but there's there's
undercurrent of thoughtfulness and
earnestness that it's very rare to
encounter in somebody who makes a living
making people laugh and now knowing a
story you know exactly where that came
from his father Yes yes right a legend
this is a man his father who went to
Vietnam to cover War zones uh and and
would come back and tell people what the
experience for those soldiers um in
Sailors and Marines was like here in the
United States I love Roy's delivery in
in his facial expressions and clearly
you see he's on a mission he has a game
plan and I think that he's so ready for
this moment I think he's ready for this
moment this is a big deal we'll all be
there Saturday well Saturday cheering
him yeah the show Roy yes and the point
that he makes it's an honor to be there
with the president of the United States
but it's more important that he
recognizes there are people in that room
who are pushing against things that keep
America from moving forward and he has
something to say when you have the
microphone well done Vlad